a parte de encuentra la distancia total
recorrida por la partícula en el
intervalo de tiempo cero menor o igual
que t menor o igual que 3 vamos a
iniciar dibujando los ejes coordenadas
aquí y ojo tú no vas a hacer esto en el
examen y en especial bajo la presión que
vas a estar resolviendo tu examen así
que cuando t es igual a cero dónde está
la partícula bueno nos habían dicho que
x de 0 es igual a 0 y lleve 0 es igual a
menos 4 así que esta es la posición de
la partícula que es 0 menos 4 y esto es
para ti igual a 0 en el problema
anterior ya resolvimos la posición de la
partícula cuando t es igual a 3 x es
igual a 21 digamos que el 21 está aquí y
ya de 3 es igual a déjame ver si
recuerdo bien era menos 3 así que esto
será el 21 menos 3.226 digamos
y esto ocurre para ti igual a 3 y entre
estos dos puntos bueno no estamos muy
seguros de la trayectoria podría parecer
a algo como esto aunque bueno no estamos
muy seguros ahora nos preguntan cuál es
la distancia total recorrida o también
lo puedes pensar cuál es la longitud
total de esta trayectoria hay una
fórmula para calcular la longitud de
arcos si la sabes pues solo podrías
aplicarla esta sería una buena idea para
tu examen y en especial cuando estás
bajo presión pero a mí siempre se me
olvidan de estas fórmulas
tal vez sea por mi edad siempre me gusta
reconstruir las y eso es lo que vamos a
hacer ahorita y también esto sirve para
recordarnos porque la fórmula funciona
podríamos empezar a pensar qué pasa si
tomamos un pequeño segmento del arco un
creo que mejor lo escoge desde este otro
lado y ahora lo voy a pintar aquí para
tener más detalle y ver cómo nos lo
imaginamos
pensemos esto como un acercamiento
así que aquí podemos identificar un
pequeño incremento en x y lo voy a
dibujar aquí
y aquí está de equis
tenemos un pequeño incremento en jet
también y aquí está de pie
si esto es especialmente pequeño
podremos pensar que esto de aquí es una
línea recta esta sería la base esta
sería la altura y esta sería la
hipotenusa que lo que aproxima a este
segmento es una línea recta que es
nuestra hipotenusa que se vería más o
menos como esto y la conocemos muy bien
por el teorema de pitágoras claro ya
sabemos que es la raíz de de x cuadrado
más de cuadrado sólo estamos aplicando
el teorema de pitágoras pero ahora como
re escribiríamos esto en función de t ya
sabemos que de x el dt es igual a x
prima de t y a partir de esto podríamos
encontrar dt y si tratáramos las
diferenciales como números que no es muy
riguroso entonces podemos decir que de x
es igual a ex prima de t de t
y también sabemos que deje en dt será lo
mismo que la derivada del ente
multiplicamos ambos lados por dt y
obtenemos de d es igual la prima de t de
t lo que estoy haciendo aquí es
simplemente reformular la ecuación del
arco
y lo vamos a llamar de de que será bueno
de él por algo pequeño bueno la verdad
no es tan importante ahorita como lo
vamos a llamar pero mejor regresemos a
nuestra expresión y ahora reescribir la
en términos de lo que ya tengo aquí y
acá y al hacer esto tendré todo en
términos de t y entonces lo que obtengo
es que ahora será la raíz cuadrada de de
equis cuadrada pero de x cuadrada será
lo mismo que haber voy a poner un color
magenta de x prima de t de t al cuadrado
y tenemos más de g al cuadrado y al
cuadrado será lo que tengo aquí o sea
prima de tdt al cuadrado ahí voy a
ajustar aquí mi radical
así que nuestra longitud de arco es esta
que tenemos aquí podríamos empezar
factor izando de t cuadrada y será igual
a 7 igual a detea al cuadrado que está
multiplicando
x prima de t al cuadrado más prima de t
al cuadrado y aquí se ve que con
facilidad puedo sacar a la dt del
radical
porque la raíz cuadrada de de t al
cuadrado es simplemente de t
simplifica a esta parte que está aquí
que es x prima de t al cuadrado más
prima de t al cuadrado
dt
pero no queremos encontrar la longitud
nada más de este pequeño arco queremos
encontrar el de toda la trayectoria la
suma de todos los pequeños que hay en la
trayectoria así que lo que vamos a hacer
ahora será integrar todos los dt es la
suma infinita de todas las pequeñas de
test que van desde t igual a 0 hasta t
igual a 3 así que ahora vamos a hacerlo
observemos que ya nos dijeron que es x
prima de t y se prima de t así que ahora
vamos a reescribir la expresión que será
la integral de 0 a 3 de la raíz cuadrada
y esquila voy a hacer bastante larga el
radical de x prima de t al cuadrado pero
aquí nos indican que x prima de t es
igual a 4 temas 1 así que aquí pongo 4
temas 1 al cuadrado más de prima de t al
cuadrado más prima de t al cuadrado
el seno de t al cuadrado así que aquí es
seno de t al cuadrado
y observa tengo que elevar todo esto al
cuadrado
y después de té
y en esta integral no es tan fácil de
encontrar la anti derivada pero la
suerte que tenemos es que en estos
exámenes podemos usar calculadoras así
que este será el trabajo difícil y
utilizaremos esta función integral
definida que está aquí
vamos primero al catálogo de funciones y
nos vamos a las f
y aquí está la integral definida ahora
tenemos que escribir todo esto en la
calculadora
o sea la raíz cuadrada de y aquí voy a
escribir todo en términos de x porque es
más fácil hacerlo con la calculadora
así que la raíz d
4 x 1
al cuadrado
más
así que el seno el seno de x cuadrado y
aquí lo tengo que indicar muy bien todo
esto lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado si
osea el paréntesis me indica de dónde a
dónde estoy elevando algo al cuadrado
ahora indicamos donde termina el radical
ahora debo de indicar cuál es mi
variable de integración que es x podría
haber utilizado t también no hace mucha
diferencia y ahora lo voy a hacer de 0 a
ahora dejemos que la calculadora haga
todo el trabajo que tenemos aquí y vamos
a obtener
démosle un poquito de tiempo obtenemos
obtenemos 21.09 1 si aquí es igual a
21.09 1 así que esta es la longitud de
todo el arco
esta es la distancia total recorrida